Finally a movie where I can screw up someone else's life and not my own.
Black Mirrors' Bandersnatch is the best choose-your-own-adventure
since Beware the Purple Peanut Butter, but this modern take provides some twisted psychological scares,
And I'm here to decipher every possible ending as well as provide some
Easter eggs along the way. Stick around 'til the end of this video or I'll include a link to a map where you can find
out how exactly to get every ending so put on some tea and get ready to take the plunge
Because we have a deadline to get to the first and easiest
Ending you may have encountered occurs roughly 10 minutes in when deciding whether to take the owner of Tucker softs
Development deal if you're a dumb-dumb like me and clicked accept the game was completed in time for Christmas
But due to it being severely rushed is given a 0 out of 5 stars.                                    [On screen: Your verdict? No stars out of 5, terrible.]
Stefan has given up his artistic integrity in order to make a
subpar product for a big expanding company                                            Stephen: I should try again
In essence he's become a sellout in this distinction between artistic integrity and the corporate chill is personified by Colin Rickman and
Mohan tacker
Respectively Mohan says of Colin this man could afford a Lamborghini but still prefers to roll his own cigarettes
For Colin video game design isn't about the money. It's about the art and just to nail home this dichotomy
Guess who makes the assistant go out and get them pre rolled cigarettes and a lion bar the greedy CEO, of course
Happy birthday
And the lion will become synonymous with the packs demon who will get into a bit more later
The second ending comes after Stefan agrees to the deal
but after weeks of
frustration begins to break down
when his father comes to take him out to the pub were given the choice of throwing tea on his computer or shouting at the
dude
who just wants to give him a free meal and since tea and
electronics don't mix his work is destroyed and we're forced to start over just
Like Stefan if you're one of the cool cats who decides to follow Colin
you'll be treated to a psychedelic scene in which Stefan takes a drug or is drugged depending on which one you've chosen and
undergoes a hallucinatory experience
The drug itself has the picture of the lion or PAX demon who Stefan calls the thief of destiny. He's an enemy in Bandersnatch
Who essentially kills you makes you start over and is referred to as a demon by the old lady in the Jerome F Davis
Documentary Stefan puts on later the drug also parallels the experience Aldous Huxley had while writing his book the doors of perception
high on mescaline
Which Mohan refers to earlier on while on this trip Colin tells us that time is a construct and that there are many different
realities that intertwine and connect
therefore nothing we do matters and this idea of nothing we do matter is echoed as well by the old lady in the
Documentary if we have no free will and everything is already planned out for us
Who cares if we become say a murderer? It's not our fault
It's already pre-planned and to prove that none of this matters because there are multiple realities
Colin dare Stephan to jump over the edge and if you're like me and chose to go over
Well, let's just say you get our third possible ending Stephan goes splat
Our fourth ending is much more subdued after getting back from dr. Haines
Stephan is actually given a few choices as to what to do with his new
medication one option only
Available to those who didn't do the Colin
Psychedelic trip storyline is to take the pills
If you choose this you get our fourth ending in which Stephan completes the game on time
But because the pills have stifled his creativity the game comes out and is a dud the reviewer on the show
Microchip saying that it was like the Creator was on autopilot
So in this version, no one dies
Except the metaphorical creative vision of Stefan in our fifth and arguably weirdest ending if you answered that
Netflix is controlling Stefan after he refuses to throw tea on his computer
He'll break down and tell his father that he needs to see. Dr. Haynes the doctor tells him
Why the hell would you pick the most boring of endings and to remedy this asked if we should add more?
Action, and of course, we're given only two options
Yes, or fuck. Yeah
But here's where you can get one of two different endings
If you choose to leap through the window
you'll get stopped by a crew member on the set of black mare who tells Stefan that this isn't part of the script as the
Character truly has delved into the madness of this character and does not know who he is
The movie has become his reality
But if you decide to stay and fight the doctor Stefan's dad barrels in and after a swift karate chop or kicked to the balls
Whichever you chose you sick bastards, you get the same ending of him being taken away by his father screaming
Hysterically that someone from the future has been talking to him
Then things start to get a little darker if you chose to kill your father with the ashtray and bury his body all the scenarios
And in Stefan going to jail, but with little twists in between for example
If you tell Mohan you can make the deadline Colin shows up and you can kill him in like the weirdest way
Possible because there are multiple realities he just basically submits now if you can't make the deadline
it's actually random who shows up you either get Kitty who asked where Colin is and the dog eventually digs up his body in the
garden
Which was alluded to in the first scene when the father says this dog will be the death of us
Or you get Mohan who is shanked by Stefan off screen?
And Colin is arrested for drug use and if you had the total indecency to chop up your dad
Stefan will at least have enough time to finish the game and get it on store shelves
In time for Christmas, if you do this, the game will receive a five star rating
but will soon be taken off the shelves when
Stefan is found to have chopped up his dad and is promptly sent to prison
This is my personal favorite ending because we then flash forward into the future to find pearl Rickman
Colin and Kitty's daughter who we saw as a baby now all grown up and taking on the task of updating
Bandersnatch for TV platforms like Netflix what we are experienced what we're watching right now is her work
We are watching Bandersnatch and like its previous krater. It has caused her to go mad
You may have also noticed the concept drawings of lions in the background the symbol of the Bandersnatch
While experiencing an error were given the option for her to throw tea over the computer or destroy
It just like Stefan was given both of these options in the show
And finally, let's get to the safe and the mysterious passwords because one of the leads to a hidden ending
Although you're only prompted with two passwords
There are actually four in total two of which can only be accessed if you visited Colin's house and completed the psychedelic storyline
if you chose TOI is your password you'll get to revisit the
flashback scene with your mom and change the past by putting your stuffed animal underneath the bed so that mom won't be late for a
Train in the morning, thereby missing the train that will eventually crash and lead to her death
but this can't be a black mirror episode without some morbid twist and when his mom asked him if he wants to go and you
Say yes, which is a new prompt
now you end up on the train only for that one - crash -
So either way it looks like the ending proves Colin and the old documentary lady, right?
You can't change fate. It will always find a way to correct itself
But what about the other passwords?
For example, if you type in pax you'll be treated to a jump-scare of the Bandersnatch demon before being awoken from your nightmare
You'll remember pax is the name of the demon in Bandersnatch who Stefan calls the thief of destiny
If you chose JFD, you'll get another jump scare. But this time by head Decapitator and Bandersnatch author
Jerome, f davis. J ft of course being his initials and
Finally PAC PAC referred to by Collin as a government conspiracy
program called program and control
PAC actually opens the safe where Stefan finds he's been part of this government cover-up program as a test subject for years
He's constantly being watched given doses of some unknown
Substances and his traumatic memories seemed to have been manufactured in a film studio not to mention. It looks like dr
Haynes has been on it, too
The two people Stefan is trusted most in his life his dad and his doctor have turned out to be the most deceptive
I hope you stuck around for a special post-credit scene in which Stefan puts in a tape entitled
Bandersnatch demo into his cassette player on it is a bunch of unintelligible static in high-pitched ringing
And for those of you like Easter eggs
This show has a ton like the metalhead poster a nod to season four episode
Featuring killer robotic dogs the program nosedive the same title of seasons 3ds opener starring Bryce
Dallas Howard and Saint junipers the hospital where Stefan visits dr
Haynes sounds oddly close - season three's San Junipero
Let's not forget this symbol here a picture of Jerome F
Davis's glyph which he used to map out Bandersnatch, which looks just like the white bear mass
Some of the patrons in season two's white bear episode would wear dr
Hanes first initials the letter R. And the owner of season fours black Museum was in our Haines
Could they somehow be related in this paper clip is chock-full of surprises
Including an article titled the love machine referencing a futuristic love machine like season fours hang the DJ
space fleet the favorite show of USS callisters meth daemon and
15 million merits which references a show called hot shot which was a show in season 1 in which contestants would battle it out to
gain, their freedom briefly at Tucker Soph
We see a poster for pig in a poke a reference to season One's national anthem episode in which the Prime Minister Michael callow
Must have sex with a pig in order to save his daughter
He's also mentioned later in the news ticker winning a celebrity bake-off right next to one about a prototype pollinator drone
Which was used in season three's hated in the nation
there's also a reference to Liam Monroe the character who controlled a cartoon bear named Waldo who becomes a dictator in season two's the
Waldo moment and finally a nod to season fours crocodile when UK police test groundbreaking memory-recall device
Which is used by police investigators to nab suspected criminals
But one of the things I loved about this episode was its attention to detail, for example
Depending on which cereal you chose at the beginning it will play that cereals commercial later on when Stefan tries to hook it up to
The VCR. I also enjoyed its underlying discussion of fate versus free
Will you have Colin who essentially argues fate controls our lives therefore nothing matters? Well in other hand we have dr
Haynes who believes there is free will but nothing we can do to stop the past or you can take the dark approach of the
documentary lady and say the only thing that exists is the illusion of free will
black mirror doesn't tell us what to think about these hefty topics rather provides different mirrors for which we can
Reexamine the world we live in but if there's anything this episode has taught us
It's that our actions have consequences
And we can go back and change them but life isn't like Netflix and it doesn't have a replay button
if only it that simple I
Hope you enjoyed this video and give it a thumbs up. I have a ton of new videos on the horizon
So make sure you're subscribed
With the Belon and I love hearing what types of shows or movies you'd like me to do next if you're looking for that link
About getting a specific ending check out my link below in the description and until next time remember daddy loves you very much